[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nbc sports and the golf channel live
from the masters
more than 50 hours of live coverage
analysis on golf channel prime time
coverage airs each night next week
beginning monday brandel chamblee is
already in augusta part of the studio
coverage the augusta national women's
amateur that airs on nbc it starts to
saturday at noon eastern and uh randall
chamblee joins us on the program brandel
if i said to you a month ago phil
mickelson won't be in the masters and
tiger woods might be in the masters what
would you have said
i wouldn't have been surprised
really figured
yeah i didn't figure phil was going to
be in the masters i mean i'm assuming
you're talking about
after the fallout from phil's comments
at the genesis i didn't figure that phil
would be at the masters but
after watching tiger woods at the father
son what was that december of last year
and then also the same week of genesis i
saw somebody put out on twitter that
tiger had walked up he had descended or
ascended the the hill behind the 18th
green at genesis without any problem
whatsoever and that's a you've ever been
to riviera and that's straight up and
that's about i don't know a hundred foot
climb up there and they said he just
clipped up that hill no problem
i thought well the combination of the
shots he was hitting at the father son
the fact that he was able to get up that
hill it sounded to me like
uh he was gonna he was gonna be back at
the masters uh every time i talked about
it i thought i don't know 50 50 60 40.
but it really doesn't surprise me having
said that it'll be
uh by far the most uh dominant story
is phil
suspended
like why is he not at the masters
that's a good question you know i i
would only be guessing it it seems like
he's suspended to me uh it'd be hard for
him after
the things that he said coming back and
going okay boys let's have some fun
let's play some golf and and look like
he was benefiting from the world of
professional golf after he at least in
my view tried to take a blow torch to
the whole pga tour
in doing so in such a transparently
greedy way
but the pga and the masters have
different set of rules
so the pga might have suspended him but
the that that have to come under the
auspices of the masters as well
yeah exactly right uh the the four major
championships are not run by the pga
tour they have their their own set of
rules and ordinances so to whatever
extent you know i i doubt he's suspended
from augusta national uh
but
along those lines i think for tiger or
excuse me for phil to come back and just
play one event
uh and imagine if he showed up here
uh he would be
hounded from start to finish everywhere
he went
with questions about his comments it
just would be
it'd be a circus and i'm sure phil
doesn't want that i'm sure augusta
national doesn't want that all right
when does tiger have to make it official
that he's going to tee it up
well he's he's officially listed on the
website of augusta national as as in the
field so i it can't get any more
official than that i suppose
you know
he
the idea of him coming up here to play
was to see if he could walk the golf
course uh you know i mean i'm sure
that's essentially what everybody was
thinking about what he was doing here
uh and if he couldn't do it and couldn't
compete couldn't hit the shots he i
think would have withdrawn by now
so you know i i think there's a pretty
darn good chance we're going to see him
walk in these fairways come monday or
tuesday of next week
have you seen him
i haven't i am just the video i saw a
video of him posted a friend of mine
played in front of him at uh at his golf
course down in west palm beach said he
turned around he said he looked like he
was walking fine he wasn't in the cart
he was walking the golf course
he looked like he was swinging fine you
know the shots that he hit at the
father-son
you know i don't know if you were
watching that event but i mean that
event out rated
many of the rounds of the majors last
year not all of them but some of them
just just a hit and giggle with tiger
woods and his son charlie outraged major
championship events and and he hit some
stunningly good shots and had plenty of
ball speed
i thought maybe he's showing up and
he'll do the ceremonial first tee with
jack nicklaus and then he and his son
maybe
you know they his son gets to play the
par three and tiger gets to caddy for
him
like that he's he's going out there to
try to win this tournament
you know when he played when he showed
up here in 2019 i mean by then we had
already seen everything we needed to see
pretty much to know that his game
was pretty much back but there were
still some question marks whether or not
he could draw it to fade it off for one
and whether or not his putting was where
it needed to be and we we found out very
early on that week that everything was
fine
this week there's more questions
obviously how's his back holding up uh
he's he's what is he 500 days from the
last time he played 500 almost 600 days
from the last time he played golf so
he's now 46 years old uh he won here
when he was 43 i mean that's at that age
when time kicks you in the teeth
uh so you know back issues this is crazy
randall randall this is crazy like
you know we we keep being surprised by
stories in sports and you think you've
seen everything and i know ben hogan
came back from a terrible car accident
but yeah
i mean tiger we thought maybe he could
lose his leg and then we thought well is
he going to be able to walk okay now can
he swing a golf club
now can he walk a course now can he win
the masters like come on this is crazy
well with him all bets are off i mean
you've seen it i've seen it you know he
has a capacity for miracles unlike
anybody else but you know it is the
comeback story of great athletes that
those are the most compelling stories of
all
in all sport you mentioned ben hogan
hollywood made a movie about that you
know there was a you know the boxer
james braddock the cinderella man
hollywood made a movie about that i mean
that comeback was inconceivable but here
tiger woods he's already given us i
don't know i've lost count of how many
comebacks but he's come back from a
broken leg
won the u.s open a sort of a a broken
image
a broken short game
and then you know ascended to 82 and won
a master so those are all hollywood
worthy this one
this one just goes right to the
ridiculous if he's able to come back
from this and play with any semblance of
the game that he had prior to it does he
have any say input on who he would play
with
on thursday
friday
you know i don't think he would but it
wouldn't surprise me that like justin
thomas is yeah exactly you know they're
gonna put him with a comfortable
favorable
pairing you know i
i can't imagine they're gonna put him
with sergio garcia you know um you know
somebody who he has a little animus with
i just don't see that i don't see that
happening uh best player in the world
right now is
well
not number no i don't want number one i
want if we were gonna bet today
best number one player and they went
right out and played right now at
augusta
one round
i i would say justin thomas
you know when i
yeah when i when i look at
the top 20 players in the world there
are more question marks than there are
exclamation points and you know you go
down the list and you start looking at
who could who has every who checks every
box here there's really only a handful
of players that sort of check every box
being able to hit the necessary height
of the iron shots being able to scramble
having the you know the sort of
the the wits about you to hit the right
shots at the right moment on this golf
course there's really only about a
handful of them here scottie scheffler
is certainly that in that handful colin
moore cow is in that handful
but justin thomas at least in my view is
is the player i'm most looking at to win
this week i tell people if you haven't
walked augusta you don't realize how
hilly it is might be the hilliest course
that they have on tour
and i just i don't know how you hold up
four days no golf cart gonna be hitting
balls
gonna have to have probably have
swelling i mean
right it's a monumental task here
right too much hill to climb when you
when you look at it that way but on the
other hand if you just look at right if
he can if he can do that and i don't
doubt from the last time we saw him
where he was hobbled a little bit better
he got around a little bit better than i
thought but so it's been four months and
tiger woods said every single day he was
emphatic about this every single day
he there is no day off for him he
realizes the door is shutting
but from a major stand major
championship standpoint
this is the best chance for him to win a
major championship it's got the smallest
field and then you can further reduce
this field down to i don't know the
average
world ranking of the winner is 11 here
over the last 10 years i mean it really
does reduce the field down to a very
small number of players
and tiger woods realizes he's he comes
here he's got to be 10 15 guys and if he
can just get around
we've seen him hobble around before and
win a major championship
you know 2008 us open he could hardly
walk is the coverage being planned for
tiger playing
i i'm sure it is you know i i'm sure
once they realized there was a very good
chance tiger was going to be here and
does he go in the afternoon brandel on
thursday to capitalize on ratings
yeah that would be my guess uh that
would be my guest dan you know just you
know first out you know i mean people
sent a room executives like what what
would they rather see a high rating on
thursday or a high rating on friday yeah
but wherever it's at the ratings will
triple because
i mean they triple when tigers just in
the event anyway but given this comeback
who knows i mean these these might be
the single greatest ratings in the
history of major championship
early on early days anyway
are you in your hotel
i'm right in the same spot where i am
when i talk about most of the time yeah
and they haven't changed the picture
behind you
no but i think that's appropriate that's
the view i have you know chipping out of
the you know the trees quite often
[Laughter]
i think somebody's trolling me yeah
hey uh great to talk to you as always
we'll be watching this week and next
week as well
thanks dan always pleasure that's
randall chamblee the lead golf channel
studio analyst and they got the
augusta national women's amateur that's
going to air on nbc saturday at noon
eastern